draft week rolls on here at Sims and
left oh oh baby oh baby good show today
we just got done talking to mr. Josh
Rosen and mr. Bradley chub I'm usually
one that does not like to talk to draft
prospects on the telephone yeah what are
you supposed to ask them are you excited
where do you think you're gonna go but
those guys were honestly really good
Josh Rosen you looked at me the entire
time was like I've never seen left go
react to somebody like that no I have
not I mean his answers were they were
awesome I mean you know you're just such
a mature different type of talker that
you hear out of the quarterback position
at this point of their life I mean yeah
he's thought about things maybe a little
more in-depth than most people his age
and I thought Bradley chubbiness kind of
connected we came up with some nicknames
whichever teams he ends up going to when
he wants to hang out with us yes he does
right this is why it's hard to meet
people because the biases from now on
I'm gonna speak so highly of them no
matter what happens you're biased I know
well I'm like Sam darn old yesterday I
know I'm biased now I know why I hear
you I mean well it just makes you not
want to say ever anything bad about them
ever but it won't change me no no I just
think I got to evaluate football you
know I know it's not gonna change you
because one of the first things you said
this morning I said yeah one of the
first YouTube comments about Sam darn
'old was look how tiny his hands are and
you were like it's all I looked at the
entire time it's they were tiny right
it's it's a it's the thing that another
piece again just gonna say it for the 9
million time he's definitely one of the
top 20 players in the draft I understand
that and that's a compliment
it is a compliment and he could be a
star in this league but again for the
pic to Cleveland it's concerning to me
with small hands that type of motion
he's from Southern California and if
anybody's ever been to the stadium in
Cleveland past September it's always
cold and it's always windy because it's
built right on Lake Erie
hashtag mistake by the lake oh right I
mean that's where it is so they have a
a different weather pattern there and
that's where I look at it and just comb
it I'd be I'd be scared of that formula
right there that would be my number one
thing right away I'd go oh I don't know
if that makes sense funny Peter King and
his article talked about Buffalo loving
Josh Allen because of their weather and
how he would play there right Buffalo in
Cleveland I mean those franchises are
always linked and part of the reason is
the weather and the lack of saying the
lake effect right it's the lake of
feather and and and everything I know
about the Buffalo Bills is that they are
not going to trade up for any of these
quarterbacks unless it's Josh Allen so
that just tells you where they were just
weird because your mock draft yeah I
know well I did it the way I done yes
you would do I know and and I get that
but I do look at that and just you know
again that fits would that New England
Brian day balls the new offensive
coordinator up there yeah and they don't
want quarterbacks that don't have then
aren't six four above 215 pounds and
gotta have hands that are above I can't
remember our number I think good you had
to have above 10-inch hands
yeah well Sammy D Sam darling was 9 and
3/8 right I have bigger hands the same
doors yeah I know
and then Baker Mayfield was what nine
and a quarter so it doesn't necessarily
make you feel better the only reason I
would feel a little bit better about
Baker is just because his motion is a
little bit more natural and a little
less right you know that herky-jerky
nough swift the arm well it's funny
you're saying Baker it is man
Cleveland's been linked to every
quarterback the rumors right now I've
reached a point where my advice to you
guys we don't listen to any of them
don't get excited
but shefter came out this morning and
said look there is a Baker Mayfield is
definitely in the running for the first
pick in the draft and he talked about
how Scott McLuhan is now a lead advisor
to John Dorsey the former GM of the
Washington Redskins and he loves Baker
Mayfield so there's a chance what I took
from this story is what's going on with
shefter what they literally look at
these last few months and I would say to
him too I'm seeing a lot of wishy-washy
reporting out of shefter these last few
weeks one throwing this Mayfield rumor
out there when okay you're gonna connect
a few dots and do all that I get it
and we at the Tom Brady story where he
said have we gotten an official answer
that Tom Brady is absolutely playing I
believe he is but I haven't heard that
officially and then that turned into a
news story the Odell Beckham jr. story
where he kind of came out there and was
like I think he's going to get traded
right but he might not get traded but I
think he's gonna get traded well then he
then he also sent out the thing about
you know league executives tell me the
Giants are knocking at a trade Odell
Beckham jr. which I took as there was no
thing which is go ahead finish this is
gonna be one of two things either chef
ders reaching a point where he's hedging
his bets all the time or we're taking
every time that shefter tweets and
making it a news story I don't remember
shefter being wishy like Adam Schefter
to me is like a woge bomb for the NFL
when he tweets something it's fact yeah
but the problem is he's he's not
tweeting facts right now he's not saying
facts so either we're listening too
closely to everything he's saying or
chef ders hedging his bets a lot lately
and either way I don't like it yeah it
just doesn't feel right he's he's giving
information out there but I think but
also you always have to be careful about
it shefter has more information than
anybody am i he's number one man he's
the gate cam and more they know
everybody owners coaches I mean their
depths of their reach are so much
farther than the people realize I mean
coaches don't even realize like I've
told you about stories with me in the
past with certain of these insiders
where the coach got mad at me like you
must have said something to Mort or
somebody and then I found out down the
road that you know that mortar that
insider found out from our owner and had
the you know what I mean so they don't
even realize the connections that are
made I think this is the thing that you
have to take into account this time of
the year because shefter also released
that whole thing about like I'm hearing
from League executives that the Giants
are not talking about trading Odell
anymore when I read that I just said oh
he's doing the Giants a solid that's all
he's doing
you got to realize he's gonna play
politics to to get his information and
teams use him to put out information in
there to shape the narrative that's my
issue so I understand that but that's
part of his job to he's not giving you
anything definitive out there but ya
take it with a grain of salt
this time of the year because there is
so many people with so many different
agendas coaches front office people
agents are all pushing their own
personal agenda you think he's doing the
Browns a solid float in the Mayfield
thing yeah to try and hopefully get the
news breaking of who they will actually
take it number no I think he's doing it
because either hold on I think the brand
when I think of things like this I think
the Browns told somebody else that may
feel still and play hoping that they
would tell a shifter or somebody like
that because now the Jets who sounds
from all that they're obsessed with me
same day like Mayfield right so now they
could be sitting there going oh okay
wait if they're gonna take Mayfield do
it do we make that move or do we have to
trade up too because we heard the Giants
do like Donald the best too so now do we
they I think I think I don't know it's
just politics that's all I'm trying to
just I don't know I'm just saying yeah I
don't like to be caught up in the fray
yeah and that's what it feels like he's
doing right I'd like for me I guess the
reporting of stories was always sacred I
understood manipulating and doing favors
but now it seems this just seems obvious
yeah it seems obvious however about
Odell Pat Shermer came out this morning
and said Odell will absolutely be on the
Giants Nexus we figured out that all 31
teams want him through trade and he's
awesome so we're gonna we're gonna keep
him because we're gonna have a riot on
our hands if we trade maybe the greatest
receiver in the history of the sport I
do like the narrative lately that a lot
of people are talking about is it's very
interesting that all of these bad
stories came out about Odell when the
contract was being discussed and the one
thing that I'm going to try and chart is
when big-name players are up for free
agency do these stories continue to
somehow get leaked because I'm that's
really interesting you know that's a big
PR manipulation
well Odell we would have given you that
big money if you didn't go out there and
do all that see you like the Giants
realize like a month ago and I'm pretty
sure I said it they they came to the
revelation wait we have zero freakin
power in this
zero they have zero nothing so they have
to play it's smart if they piss off
Odell Beckham jr. he says screw the New
York Giants I'm never playing them again
trade value down if he doesn't agree to
a trade in a long-term deal with that
team that they want to trade with
there's no trade that happens so he has
all the power and almost he's almost has
a no trade clause in his contract
without it I mean he's that powerful at
this point and I think the Giants
realized that I don't think the whole
Odell trade things dead yet I won't
believe that until next Saturday man
that's when I will say okay teams are
good with their roster they're gonna go
from now on I'm excited I'm not giving
up that that their phones they're not
gonna hang up and go oh no no we won't
take to first or Odell sorry you're
gonna need like an alarm on the desk
that if an Odell trade happens you just
lose our minds and our heads explode
speaking of kind of like rumors and all
that stuff
Sean Payton came out and confirmed
something that you said a year ago that
Pat mahomes was number one on their
board and they were gonna take him on 11
yeah and then the Chiefs traded up to
ten and took them yeah
old Chris shefter over here yeah just
it's good to hear those things every now
it makes me just feel better about the
people I talked to they go okay yeah I
was right they told me the right thing
there that's for sure that's what we
always thought yes that would have been
fascinating to see my homes there oh my
but I think the point you made too I
mean it might have worked out for the
better they one of my homes didn't get
on the ended up with Lattimore the best
corner in the draft oh they wanted
Rueben foster didn't get him Oh got Ryan
Ram [ __ ] yeah kind of worked out kind of
worked out exactly right and I think you
agreed that we're gonna continue our
tradition if you didn't watch the draft
was with us last year after the Niners
selected Salomon Thomas you called Kyle
I don't think he still knows that but I
picked up and we were live on the show
and it was an amazing moment after the
ninth pick in the draft even if he
doesn't pick up call that man up again
okay really we just make it a yearly
tradition we don't tell him yeah I mean
I'm not I mean if I tell him he will
definitely not answer so he listens to
this podcast which he might be one to do
yes but it was funny because your face
last year for the draft
like yeah he's not gonna pick up and
then a Suzy picked up you like hey I
wonder don't say you think they're
listening you feel good one last thing I
think it's an interesting development is
the Eagles white house a lot of people
are going wow you know it's been a few
months now are the Eagles gonna go to
the White House many of the players have
already come out and said right after
the Super Bowl Malcolm Jenkins Chris
long Brandon Graham we're not going well
the Eagles released a statement and in
part of their statement yesterday it
said we're honored to receive this
invitation and view this not only as an
opportunity to be recognized for
on-field accomplishments but also as an
opportunity to engage in productive
dialogue with the leaders of our country
I have gone to the White House
I covered Louisville when they won that
national championship and I saw what
they do to honor those guys there is
about I don't know 30 seconds of actual
dialogue between the President of the
United States and the team but I'm
really hoping the Eagles are going know
we'll go if you actually give us the
dialogue that you constantly say is
available when teams go or I really hope
the Eagles just send Malcolm Jenkins and
Chris long and go we're here for the
dialogue we're here for the sit-down
that's what I would love I mean that
would be amazing
yes we don't want the photo-op we don't
need it we just really want to do some
dialogue as the woke esteem in the
country as the team that has people that
went into the community and help change
things and fought for civil rights we'd
like to talk to you now I just think
that would be great I mean that would be
phenomenal but we thought that's not
happening and I'd have a hard time
thinking than the Eagles just are gonna
go in general because I mean I did I've
read something yesterday - they were
like Jeff Jeffrey Lurie yes was one of
the biggest people do talk during the
order he called the Trump's presidency
of an effing disaster so I mean I would
have a hard time thinking that they're
gonna attend that what if they were like
we're more interested in meeting Melania
right I just think there's a lot of
opportunities here for the Eagles to do
some stuff to make it different but they
might also be the first team to like not
go at all that could be interesting yeah
they could be
I know listen you know my thoughts I
wouldn't go that's just the way I feel
yeah I would not go there's no way I
would ever attend that I can't even go
in the John George restaurant in the
Trump building on Columbus Circle I've
refused to I'm sorry for all you out
there that are maybe support him I
respect your ability to support of it I
just don't like the person I'm really
sorry I don't mean to offend
yeahit's look we're just shy have family
members and people that voted for him so
I I'm I can I'm okay you understand him
well one guy that's been very vocal
about it I think it scared a little bit
of teams was Josh Rosen of course wore
the eff trump hat to the Trump golf
course I want to tell you that I have
interviewed a lot of young people in my
life in the 18 to 22 year range teddy
bridgewater blew my socks off I was at
college over the years Carson Wentz I
shook his hand I went I trust this man
Sam darn on yesterday was great I've
never heard the words put together like
our guy Josh rose and the rose and one
gave us and so here he is Josh Rosen on
the Sims of left go podcast what's up
man how you doing you ready for this
whole process to get over with all right
look by the way Josh yeah we're going
yeah really excited I mean it's been an
awesome process I mean you just meet a
lot of cool people it's been fun it's
been too long it's definitely been I've
definitely been long but I mean it's
been good have been learning a lot I
mean a lot of cool people and doing some
things basically I've been dreaming
about doing since I've been a kid yeah
that's all growing up in Manhattan Beach
enjoying the Sun on his face just was a
Josh Rosen joins us thanks to Old Spice
read collection of premium sense
including new captain designed help guys
everywhere to step up their scent game
without breaking the bank
learn more about the red collection at
Old Spice calm the rows in one Rosen
would best nickname I've ever heard yes
as a member of the tribe I gravitated
toward is it immediately
Josh I a simple question what have you
learned about our society's relationship
with intelligence throughout this whole
process what it wouldn't what do you
mean by that like I find you to be an
intelligent person that can see through
facades
and it seemed like you got punished for
that and I'm just curious from your
perspective what have you learned about
how we treat smart people
I think being authentic is starting to
be applauded a little bit more and more
I think social media really gives you a
behind-the-scenes look on who people are
I mean back in the day with with like
movie stars and old studio heads they
would keep them as hidden from public as
possible the only people think people
would ever know about them is is like
what movies are in and whatnot now your
people are on YouTube people on
Instagram they're doing stories or other
stuff so people actually value
authenticity and I think it's slowly
intelligence and knowledge and and
knoweth all is it's it's slowly creeping
into the mainstream and it started to be
okay and if I have to be if I have to be
a sacrificial lamb a little bit and go
out there and maybe get my name dragged
around in the mud a little bit I think
it's four things for the greater good I
think it should be it should be cool to
be a good person it should be cool to be
smart it should be cool to be honest
want to do something different be honest
yeah I mean I don't get I don't
understand how the media always
complains about how they get Bill
Belichick responses of to words and all
of a sudden someone says something more
and they grill them for it
like it's it's like yeah yeah you're
right I like all right so number one
yeah so I mean this is why we like you
man I mean we talk about you a lot and
we've we've always kind of liked the
things you've said and you're outside
the box thinking at the same time and
all those things you just said you're
realizing that the NFL and the coaches
and the organizations aren't as
open-minded maybe as some of the people
in Southern California or your friends
unfortunately but like are you
frustrated with this constant I have to
defend my character and Who I am today
I would you know I you know I don't I
don't think so I'm a little bit on both
sides that going to the first point
about the NFL the only people thing
people know about the NFL is what the
media tells them I think the NFL is
actually very open I mean the NFL is a
is a it's a massive social media
initiative and they're pushing content
from from quick highlight tapes to to
combine photos there
to us encouraging us to post hmm there
are NFL teams that are talking to me and
and they're actually like we we love
that you love other things we just want
to know that you love football so I
think a lot of its misconstrued in the
media a lot of people have anonymous
sources and NSC executive something like
that that might just be complete BS or
it might I don't know whatever but I
think I think the NFL because they have
to attract eyes and attract viewers have
to be receptive to the new up-and-coming
audience and with regards to the team's
itself and who's actually picking me I
think that's why there's a scouting
process because there are certain teams
that are old school there's certain
teams that are new school there yes
seems that do certain things and the
idea is that I don't want to just go one
two or three I want to go to the routine
that I can have success for 15-20 years
down the road right I don't like Tom
Brady if you if you asked him if you
wanted to be the first pick and be out
of the league in six years or what he's
doing right now I think he would pick
this every single time yeah I don't
really care where I go as long as they
sincerely believe that I'm the best fit
for them because I promise you I'm gonna
put absolutely every ounce of effort I
have into this game to be the most
successful and I'm very confident
because they're gonna be the last man
standing in this draft cos when all is
said and done and I just I hope the team
does their homework and I hope team
picks me because they think I'm gonna be
the best fit for that organization okay
all right so I mean that your answers
are great I mean they really are this
I'm just gut feeling okay do you you
don't have to tell me the team right now
do you have a gut feeling as far as what
team you think may pick you and I want
to just second with that with if you
were to fall okay I'm not trying to be
Johnny jerk here alright cuz you're my
second favorite quarterback in the draft
sorry you're number two you're not
number one but I still love you a lot
but if you were to fall you welcome to
come back and crap all over me in a
couple years but we're not going to
forget but if you were to fall I mean
how far do you have a number two where
you go oh no I know that team right
there is not gonna let me go past that
right there so I won't tell any farther
the media has the media has
the draft is very simply like an
exercise to get a person to a team the
draft has turned it the media has turned
it into this massive event and the only
thing I care about is from a certain
threshold falling outside of the first
round in terms of money you can't afford
to invest into yourself at a certain
level like for example if you fall out
of the first round you might not be able
to afford a private chef or you might
not be able to perform afford like the
like the the private trainers or things
like that that ground is covered and I
don't have to worry about money in terms
of I can invest into my body in my
business as much as I need to anything
after that's great I don't really care
that's awesome
alright so I got a few for you here our
favorite quarterback in the NFL and it's
the best quarterback we've ever seen Oh
Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers and when I
saw you working out with him and the
questions you were asking and the
conversation you were having
I'm just curious on a personal level
what you took from that experience took
a lot
I mean he's I mean he's the greatest I
mean I you can I think he's the greatest
player at the position of quarterback I
mean he just does things people can't
and but a lot of that's not just natural
ability a lot of that's because he works
on it
he practices off-balance throws and off
platform movements and he practices
these things in practice when other
people aren't a lot of other a lot of
other guys are just trying to not get
yelled up by their coach Aaron's trying
to get better each and every day and
when you have a personality type like
that that's why people will kind of get
on me a little bit sometimes when I I've
ever been an editor coaches because I
want them to bring as much juices I got
I want them to I want to know that they
care as much about this game as I do I
don't want to just check I don't want to
just [ __ ] in and clock out and not get
fired I want to see if I can be one of
the greatest ever do it alright I keep
saying that - everything's all in on you
over the draft you go you get on the
podium and we were talking with Darnell
yesterday's like yeah I think I'm gonna
do a bro hug to Goodell Josh I got a
suggestion for you you go up there and
you do a long
extended handshake like by the time you
get on the stage your hand is already
extended and you make it a business move
in fact you do a little twist and you
land the plane a Power Move handshake
right off why what do you think you know
what I think I might just stick to the
old white guy say some words to them put
on the Jersey put on that and then get
born and start chasing Super Bowls oh I
like that all right other thing I got to
say is you realize that if you get
drafted by one of the New York teams you
are obligated as a 21 year old member of
the tribe to live in Murray Hill
tell them everybody what the tribe is
okay just everybody out there listening
I am Jewish so is rosin and every 20
year old Jewish person a part member of
the tribe you have a question well I
don't mean I don't know yeah but you
have to live in Murray Hill it's kind of
like an initiation into New York City
just so you know okay I got you one step
at a time
yeah one time one step at a time all you
to find a real estate agent perfect in
fact I'll be your real estate don't do
it Josh
Josh okay I mean it's of course a
fascinating year with the quarterbacks
right I just I want to do like I just
was thinking of something just to talk
about as far as the other guys I'm like
word-association I'm gonna give you the
quarterbacks name I want the first thing
that comes to your head out of out of
just your evaluation of them as a player
first thing oh god oh god Josh Allen
let's start there just give me like
first thing that comes to your head as
long as it's not gonna get you in
trouble
I don't know big dude big dude okay how
about Baker Mayfield hauler ball there
okay okay let's go Lamar Jackson a
baller
those two dudes are kind of guys that I
just think of you throw them on a
basketball court and they're gonna score
some points yeah that's a competitor
that's a good way to put it okay and
then how about Sam darn old
talented I think he's really good what
he does yeah
and then how about the rosin one
convicted convicted I could I have
conviction and everything that I do
there you go okay that's okay those deep
answer they're leaves a deep guy hey
that was pretty good okay I like it
again I want to thank I think if you
hang out with me and if you're on if
you're on my team you know what I'm
trying to accomplish and what I'm trying
to do every single day we don't we don't
doubt that one bit dude we've been in
your corner from the start whether you
were sitting in your hot tub in your
dorm room or whatever it was I mean we
get where you're coming I was in guy was
in your shoes once and I was dumber than
you for sure and way more wild and
that's probably why I fell to the third
round
I want to thank Old Spice is read
collection of premium sense for making
this possible Josh if you end up in New
York you're coming by Bleacher Report
we're gonna take you on the town we're
gonna make sure that you are set up for
success kick ass man we're proud of you
perfect looking forward to it I hope
that I hope that as I'm heading that 360
Old Spice keeps me fresh so that I'm not
not throwing some unnecessary sense in
the Roger Goodell's nose yeah please
don't I don't we don't need to smell you
from across the TV come on that be good
good luck man take care see ya
though rose in one I mean those he's the
answers are I know you are I mean dim
you're sweating like you've been like
flirting with the guy over here um have
you heard answers like that my kid his
age no absolutely not I mean no he's
he's a very deep thinker you know as
much as it's so funny because like I
loved him right
love Sam Donald yesterday I mean yeah
great guy left here yesterday just
telling everybody what how awesome Sam
Darnell was that was awesome as well
it's but it's like different awesome yes
funny we're like I don't even know how
to say it like josh is just a thinker
that's gonna bring angles you haven't
thought of Sam's just gonna be cool
chills
listen add his two cents and maybe throw
some dry humor on it
which I think you know percent is a
ballbuster that's going to kind of be
one of the guys immediately and he's got
like a quick three word answer that's
gonna be like loosen up yes josh is
gonna question everything but by the
time you're done you're gonna go Wow
why don't all quarterbacks look at it
like this yeah like the fact that the
difference from him between the first
round in the second round is the
amenities that he can afford to support
his foundation and not ego or not I'm
upset because I deserve to be a first
rounder he's looking at it as a process
doing it the right way the fact that he
could see the media and their inclusion
in all this the fact that and plus I
don't think that the whole conviction
thing is a gimmick I don't think that
his agent got to him and said you need
to continuously tell people that you
want to win Super Bowls right
it just sounds like it's coming right
from his gut yeah I do too I don't I
don't see I don't question any of that I
mean the only thing I I've questioned it
because I've heard some people that I
have sent my relationships around the
NFL say things like that so that when
they say that does make me go home
because they're not the type of friends
I have that say those things usually
right not that I believe every word that
they've said and not that they've been
right every time but it does make me go
huh
certainly his little speech about you
know I call to be smart at school and
I'll fall on the sward for that yeah
yeah right
awesome yes awesome I mean I'll say this
I know teams have taken him off the
board because they don't want to deal
with his attitude I know
it's crazy there's a reason Aaron
Rodgers went to and I know it's crazy it
to me he could very well end up being
the best one I mean as you know I think
he's number two but I do think and look
at it and go man he's gonna be the guy
that falls if somebody falls out of the
five you think he'll be the I think a
big I know I just be I feel like the
Jets are in on Baker too much so hard
yes and I just think rosin that's where
I was trying to get with that answer of
asking about you know the old school
mentality of the NFL right and he kind
of went into the media and he goes now
they're trying to put things out
socially I know it talked about how some
teams are old school right some teams
are new school and the only thing he
cares about it yes
do you want me and will use yeah no I
know I know I'm just saying as a whole
the league the new school teams are very
few and far between yeah and who are we
talking about Kyle John McVay who are
the teams that we respect the new school
teams yeah so I'm not gonna stand here
and go just dumb it down for those old
school teams that we think are dumb no
not necessary I'm not but I'm not gonna
say that's not always it seems we
respect - I don't think that I mean we
respect New England and Pittsburgh and
you don't think New England is new
school I think they lead the new school
I I mean no I don't is the treasurer so
McVeigh is the Secretary Belichick is
the president of looking at the league
in with a critical eye and going let's
be different yes critical eye but I
don't think they look at them wanting
then I don't think the New England looks
at wanting the new school-aged player
that's where I'm coming from they don't
want any of that they want old school
shut up do your job that's all I have a
say you know who New England likes right
Bradley Chubb yeah guy that's gonna
chase quarterbacks the chubba Nader we
talked to Bradley - and here's beach'
job you don't hello the chubster
carbonator bleacher report right so this
is the Sims and left called podcast just
to introduce ourselves we're rolling and
we're rolling so this don't say anything
too crazy unless you want to we're all
crazy stuff but you don't have to be
like dorky like you know like network TV
here we're gonna have a little fun okay
all right man heck yeah well Bradley
Chubb of course just like mr. Rosen
coming to us from old Spice's red
collection of premium sense Chubb are
you a stinky kind of dude like are you
using a lot of Old Spice how bad of
those Chubb Pitts yeah I mean I got I
sweat a lot so I gotta make sure I used
a lot of Old Spice and a lot of a lot of
the other about the body's praises
because I sweat from which yeah I'll
just be nervous all the time so nervous
where there's like the worst thing it
smell worse then uh what they call it
didn't work out sweat so oh yeah you
know I mean I know I was on the field
that Notre Dame
and I smelled you you were so nervous to
go against Mike McGlinchey I smelled
your nervous sweat you're the number one
pass rusher in the draft that's a pretty
cool honor to have do you feel like all
this quarterback talk you're looking at
them and you're going I'm gonna take
these guys down the rest of my career
yeah hopefully that's what that's the
point
I think what's cool for you man is no
matter where you go in the top five
you're getting paired up with a nasty
teammate so if you end up going to
Cleveland it's you and miles Garrett if
you end up going to the Giants it's you
and Olivier Verne if you go to the
Broncos it's you and Vaughn Miller got
you and Vaughn doing Old Spice
commercials watch out you guys will be
showering together and everything
commercial where he like grabbed he
grabbed some enlighten the strike and
then like he's like the team's watching
it yes that's probably my favorite
commercial right now which which
nickname do you like better if you end
up on Cleveland do you like your tag
team name with Miles Garrett being miles
of chub or chubbie miles you could be
Vaughn all right so one of the things I
really liked and Sims you went and cover
them and you saw how much talent was on
that NC State d line apparently so did
Bill Belichick came down and worked you
guys out what was it like working out
with Bill what did you take away from
that experience I mean he was a guy that
knew what he wanted a guy that was very
particular in the drill he wanted so I
took that from him but when he was
talking to us mainly about just the
drill wasn't like anything else so I
really did I love you too actually what
I learned from him at that time I really
learned anything just because he was
teaching the general but him being there
at the pro day and working us out was
pretty cool just because you know
usually head coaches come to pro days
and just sit around it's like
ladis counselor coaches do whatever they
do but for him they might be involved in
all that I felt like that was pretty
cool it um a lot of guys enjoy that
experience yeah seems like he's got a
man crush on you you know you're a
freaking er you're a freak of nature you
really are you're like quite the
specimen but I'm always interested in
just hearing this I mean because I know
a lot of your athletic gifts came
naturally to you but you work hard out
of all the combine things you know I
mean combines not football we both know
that I don't know if you know I played
in the NFL at one point too but also
what was the drill that gave you the
hardest time preparing for the combine
where you were just like man I can't get
my time down the three cone the five ten
five what was the biggest pain in the
butt for you either you take just big of
a step and you know like an extra time
or you take this long like the it was
like the first 10 yards in that like
you're going back and forth I know the
current part was easy just because I do
that like pretty much every play right
but going back and forth just because
you had a time to steps and I'm a guy
that has like more legs yes but but
sometimes when I run I had short stride
it was weird like oh no having to Tom
that up and and do all that so my town
wasn't the best but I mean yeah I hear I
I didn't like that drill either that was
the worst one for me hands down it is
it's a pain but especially quarterbacks
we don't have to move like that either
oh now now with the quarterback
conversation I'm sure you're sick of
hearing about the quarterbacks cuz you
know you're you're a better player and
then a lot of them in this draft but
they still get the the headlines there's
so much uncertainty in the top five
right now even you know the top 10 do
you have like you don't have to tell us
who but do you got a gut feeling yet of
where you may end up or at least like
where you like your chances to end up to
be honest I have like an idea but I
still don't know cuz like anything
happened one job day so I could train up
somebody throw you down somebody could
come back up that was down like you just
don't know so like like right now as it
is right now I have a gut feeling but I
did it down really know what's what
Thursday let's tell us justjust tell us
you're going to Cleveland at 4:00 right
should we just announce it now
because we're before no you don't you
don't know how many how many visits did
you end up going on total throughout
this whole process three but I met with
at least eight of the top ten teams and
the three visits were who that it was
the Giants the Bears and Who am I
missing on the other visit Tampa Bay so
there we go it's three teams you're not
man so I'm excited for you well what's
interesting is I read that your junior
year you change your jersey number to
nine to honor Mario Williams and then
you go out and you break all of his
records he went number one I'm just
curious why why did you do that what is
your relationship with Mario Williams no
I was so my coats honored like the
players were number so what am i he was
given to you it was like a respect thing
he thought that was showing signs of
being a leader coming off my sophomore
year and showing size improvement and
home why my grades were going up
everything was on the uprise he felt
that um he saw something in me that he
felt like I could be at that level so
where my junior year that's awesome so
that's honoring from the school
perspective and I think some people know
this you and Nick Chubb you come from
Chubb town Georgia I mean this is the
Chubb family founded this area your dad
played college football your brother
played college football
I'm just curious is Chubb on the back of
your Jersey in the NFL I mean you're
playing for a large group of people what
does that feel like it's gonna be crazy
just to have not only me by playing for
it but my brother my cousin plants boys
well so he's gonna have three people
with show on there on the back of their
jerseys I feel like that's gonna that's
gonna be huge not only for us but for
our families as well and for our like
communities because uh you know Nick
comes from a smaller town I mean my
brother came from like the suburbs big
school and had like a lot of people in
my graduating class so it wasn't like
nothing nobody was
like you know say I'm struggling or
anything but I'm not saying people in
mixed area will struggling they're a
smaller town and so like just to inspire
kids from coming from those areas
especially small towns of course just
coming from that small town and making
it big like Nick did or coming from a
rural rural area like Annie Brandon did
and being on that big stage like that I
feel like it's real cool and we're doing
stuff to not only have an impact or to
feel good for you man like it yeah I
mean you seem like you got it all
together this is one thing I always like
to ask like big-time players like
yourself about other players you played
against right that might have impressed
you one of the lightning rods of the
whole draft process like you're gonna be
trying to sack quarterbacks in the NFL
well I can promise you you've played a
quarterback in college that it's harder
to sack than all the other NFL
quarterbacks can you tell us about Lamar
Jackson and just what it was like to try
to pursue him I know you got a sack or
two in that game but what it's like to
play a guy like him at that position
very tiring hmm right I mean I mean yeah
I mean just going on him a little bit
not every player I could I mean he was
one of those guys that we had for our
meetings just the game playing around
just because he could do so much like um
we had to make sure that everybody was
just bashing but my sophomore and junior
yes right he was one of the guys that
you you just don't know what he's gonna
do so like coming from the back side a
lot uh can't see me coming but I feel
like here just like sixth sense when he
like I don't know just felt me yeah he
saw you break the huddle and he said man
that big MF for number nines over there
I'd better keep my eye on him five years
before every time I got close he would
just make one move in life I was still
like hit him and all that but it
wouldn't be you don't say make one move
to get out of it and deliver the ball
like I'm on the money so I feel like
he's one of the best better players in
the draft and he's a lot yeah he
definitely is there's no doubt about
that yeah I mean he had to be go down as
one of the hardest guys to tackle for
you and with ACC football I know but in
the open field right I mean he's it's
like tackling a top-tier running
exactly like is he so dynamic that she's
elusive and quick and all that so it's
probably like if he has you open field
it's gonna be it's over yeah I mean it's
not necessarily yeah my question for you
Brad is just about Lamar like for all of
you guys you go through this draft
process you get asked quite as equation
you get flown all over the country and
you learn a lot about the process but
hearing what people said about Lamar you
faced him I talked to Derwin James I
talked to quittin Nelson they all said
this guy is incredible and yet the
media's going he should switch to wide
receiver I was just curious from a guy
that played him what did all that mean
to you what did you learn I mean I feel
like with the media like if somebody
said something yeah people bandwagon it
young huh mm-hmm
like I get on Twitter and so I'm seeing
something about me somebody might say my
pinky is too small and then like that's
a whole whole article his pinky too
small you kidding though you know so the
I feel like the media when it comes to
stuff like this is just crazy just
because they could say anything and have
a whole a whole cult behind it that just
because they say it was right that means
is right so I'm just saying that it's
like it's it's like come on man like cuz
this news probably one of the most
decorated players that I've played
against dynamic could do everything and
for them to be like that in my - it's
hard to see well I mean can you at this
point like I know left Co brought it up
your defensive line you guys have I mean
I know you're the man but that was one
of the things you know I had to do the
pregame and halftime show for NBC and
Notre Dame and all that and then worse I
studied you during the season and I just
was blown away by all four guys but can
you did you realize how good you guys
were you know this whole time and I'd
like you to also talk about our man
Kentavious street who probably would
have been a second-round pick but
because of player workouts and He pours
ACL right you know yeah so just just
talk about that a little bit you guys
yeah so yeah I mean we all bought some
different the table I feel like Justin
was the Justin was the energy ball of
the group yes
b-day was older civil not
but like hey guys we gotta we gotta
bring this in lock it in blah blah right
and your tape Kentavious was the quiet
guy that got the job done but we I would
say we picked on him but he was like he
was so quiet he was saying aback he was
like the easy target right right but of
our group like if anybody else tried to
do anything we wouldn't let him so of us
for so um what you know just you said
did I realize it I mean yeah we realized
how good we were but we didn't realize
that we try not to think about it
because we had a coach Nicholson yeah
that never let us get on my heart let it
never let us get on our high horse right
and whenever we made a play he will find
like the smallest thing wrong with it -
always keep make sure them we were
working on improvement and everything
but we got complaints or anything so um
just playing with those guys it was fun
we all knew like I said we all do how
good we were when we just try not to
think about it
and and um to see Kentavious go down
like that it was it was sad I Texan I've
been texting them calling them all that
make sure he's all good stuff like that
it was sad to see though just because I
know the potential he had in the next
level I feel like in the he didn't make
like the most planes or whatever he had
like the stats or whatever but he was a
great player with a hot like did
everything right yes if you watch the
film you can see how dominant he was
right so um just seeing him go down we
called him sly he in high school got the
name super Street so like nobody we call
this like super Street just messing
around with him stuff he never got hurt
or anything so to see like it was like
seeing Superman go down pretty much
feels crazy so middle started to see but
I know he's gonna make the best out of
the situation and keep moving for ya
Bradley J Chubb
joining us from Old Spice red collection
of premium sensing including new captain
helping guys smell good Shabba before
you go here out of five stars
what do you give the new Jay Cole album
I saw some tweets man to be honest yes
so I'm a little in on the little story
that I like talked about this because
it's sensitive okay great I hate Jay
Cole okay so we were tell us more
laughter there's I thought this into
music you know that just because I I was
like a little I was excited to see them
and I'll tell you sir
alright so didn't Smith was at NC State
you know yeah those who were like from
the same area and all that so he came to
all the basketball games all that blah
blah and so we were doing a little toys
for tot give away a half-time like a
football team and he was going back to
his seat and we were like oh Schneider J
Cole a can we get a picture I got uh our
media lady I'm miss Annabelle
she has say can you get a picture with
our guys long bus his albums just came
out the the was a call for his hills yes
yeah that was that would just came out
and so he was like nah I'm chillin when
we had to take the picture uh man this
man I know it's probably knowing
everybody I asked him take pictures and
all that but I just felt like at the
time today you know I'm saying I got a
little quick flick can I see yeah yeah I
hear you know Bradley you know that
means you have to take pictures with
every fan that comes up to you for the
rest of your life I felt like at a time
I wasn't I wasn't getting pictures taken
all the time and all that stuff but now
you can relate yeah yeah now I can
relate so I could I could probably go
back and listen to a double but I had
like a year long road to give them cuz
if you want to listen to a rapper talk
about meditation paying your taxes and
folding clothes oh that's very
disappointed in this album yeah I know I
heard 1985 yeah it was pretty funny just
because a lot of these New Age like
rappers and stuff he was at the stuff he
was saying this is pretty funny like you
gonna be a loving hip-hop I guess it's
the truth is that yeah it is well
Bradley listen if the Giants take you at
two we are in New York and we'd like to
show you around if you get picked by the
old g-men not saying that's where you're
going I'm just extending an invitation
from Bleacher Report yep what if I get
you anywhere else yes or we'll go to you
alright good bet
Bradlee trouble guys sacking your
favorite teams quarterback beat up
appreciate you man good luck man thank
you kick butt
all right box amen sadly chop if he goes
to the Browns yes we are calling him
Chevy Mile he'll be miles he didn't like
miles of Chuck now that I say it out
loud I can kind of understand why miles
of Chuck chubbie miles
yeah and Vaughn's job sounds very
Eastern European man all right so what
do you think of all Bradley well you got
to see him in person he's a man the
second I saw him first of all on film
leading up to that game and personally I
was like okay this guy is going to be
you know everyone was already saying I
was first-round pick and I saw him on
film I said he's more than a first-round
pick this is a top 15 pick and seeing
him in person as soon as they ran on the
first of all like we talked about their
defensive line they have an NFL defense
line all four of those guys cuz I I know
that you watch them on film yes because
that's part of your job right but I
remember you came back and you said left
co every guy on that D line can play in
the NFL they are and then we started the
draft process and all these guys start
getting up put up in the first and
second round right but he's more special
than the rest he definitely is yes he's
the most physically gifted the other
guys on their defensive line were more
size predicated like we talked about
Kentavious Street tore his ACL he's the
guy that had like the 700 pound squat
during the number that video right yeah
so he would be he was gonna be more of
like a I thought it ended the second
round defense ends yeah set the edge do
everything right my question fuses
though but he every year yeah we get a
player at positions and we rank the
positions and then we say this is the
best pass rusher in a long time this is
the best running back in a long time
before there was sake one there was
Fernet before Fernet there was Zeke
before Bradley Chubb there was Miles
Garrett before miles Garrett there was
Khalil mcclain he do this every year
yeah I'm just curious where in your mind
Bradley Chubb stacks up to the other top
pass rushers the last few years yes
the the Khalil max of von Miller's the
Myles Garrideb young clown yes right
yeah he's not them he's got no III think
I I've hope I have said that from the
start but
yes I mean to me he didn't test out like
them either no he's not the total
absolute freak of nature that they are
right I mean like Jadeveon Clowney was
the same weight like miles carrying four
five some four five three in this kid
who's a freak of nature in 465 miles
carrot literally beat this guy in every
category I think can also do it between
the legs duck Miles Garrett and Jadeveon
Clowney are the type of people that only
enter football every five to six you
even put miles Karen Jadeveon above has
a freak of nature specimen yes and so
you so this guy is closer to who to me
my poker player comparison was Olivier
Vernon so if he ends up going to the
Giants they got both of those I mean
it's to me that he's a can't-miss
prospect does he have the superstar
high-end talent like we talked about
with the other guys no I don't see that
but like his his floor is like 10 year
starter and a few Pro Bowls like he's
there's he could be a guy that one year
you get 14 sacks the next year it might
be seven or eight but he's gonna be
awesome at everything you asked me to
run great at there were seen plenty of
clips of him getting out in coverage
he's the thing that's the most
impressive about him is his motor really
which is funny because the last few
years that's been the number one
question for a lot of guys Jadeveon
Clowney doesn't seem to hustle on
everybody this guy goes nuts every play
nuts might follow up to being too you
would be if he played on such a deep
defensive line yes was he getting rest
too no I mean they played the whole game
no he did not play they did not like
substitute the D and I was impressed
with the amount I wouldn't say it up
great motor if I was only doing like 30
snaps again he really was impressive to
the point where I was like damn this is
PI 75 and the pedal is still in the
metal Jason Lamar Jackson Wow he's
tremendously twitchy
he's got great quickness like to fake
outside and come inside on a defensive
lineman he can go speed to power and he
can beat you with straight speed as well
my biggest knock with him as compared to
maybe some of the other great pass
rushers we've seen and we're comparing
them the great yes or even like even
where I give like a Harold Landry an
advantage of
in this truck is his his bend around the
edge is not like super star Bend around
the edge where you know you see the Von
Miller pictures or the cool Mac pictures
where they're like thank you sometimes
they can come around the edge right and
they're like they're inside shoulder can
be almost close to their inside foot
Vernon doesn't have that Bend Vernon
yeah no he does not and that's why there
look at that way right like they also
great against the run because they're
not selling out as much exactly right
like he's gonna dominate tight ends when
they try to block him and the strength
of the point of attack verse first-round
left tackles like Mike McGlinchey who we
got to see like that's the great thing
about the ACC right now that you get to
see them the Louisville left tackle is
gonna be playing in the NIV here so
you're gonna you get to see it all chase
Lamar Jax it's one of the reasons I'm so
high in Lamar Jackson cuz the ACC is
pretty damn good right now and I see a
lot of NFL players on the field and they
can't tackle Lamar Jackson and he throws
the ball by Derwin James and those kind
of guys get to talk to an NFL draft
prospect right who's not amazed by oh
that doesn't look at Lamar Jackson go
that's a special human yeah it's just
you know there are certain guys that are
physically different than everybody else
Bradley Chubb is one of those guys
Quinton Nelson is one of those guys you
know Tremaine Edmonds is one of those
guys and I think our guy here Bradley
chose one of those guys alright so that
was mr. Rosen and mr. Chubb yeah good
guys great guys I like them I'm in man
it's the whole draft I I haven't liked
everybody's personality so far even
people we have an interview but just
people have seen just throughout the
process like yeah they're waiting for a
guy to really hate there is no guy to
here
no one likes your sterling personality
so tomorrow is going to be a very big
show we are gonna be doing a crossover
podcast with the stick to football guys
Connor Rogers and Matt Miller we are
gonna set up on this tape hall at Sims
in left Co though right it's gonna go on
both podcast really called Sims and left
cuz then it'll be stick to Sims and
lefke that's how we're gonna combine the
two together the chubby miles of
podcasts but what we're gonna do is I'm
going to be the GM Sims
give me my director of player pro player
personnel Miller will run college
scouting and Connor will be my Regional
Scout I'm going to put 15 minutes on the
clock
we're gonna get through the top five
picks and you guys are gonna have to
convince me if it takes suppose to go
through a pick we're doing this wrong
hopefully we can like if we have to go
really here you have to make a decision
I'm not gonna be doing a lot of talking
I might be doing interrupting I don't
know if I'm gonna be doing a lot of
talking I'm I don't think people
understand why I'm so excited for this
drift five years
you me and Miller have been doing the
giraffe together five years ago you and
Miller did about a thousand videos
before the draft and your opinions they
have to naturally get closer together
every year we've done a little bit less
just because what we've done it bleacher
report has trained changed when I tell
the people that you and Miller have not
even talked I have no idea what you're
gonna disagree about I don't know what
you're going to agree about so tomorrow
will be crazy and Thursday Bleacher
Report Facebook live and in the BR app
for the draft I think it's gonna be a
maze we're streaming on the BR app
streaming on the baby technology is
wonderful that takes able to figure this
out huh so super excited about it
tomorrow it'll be the roundtable and
then we're also gonna have on Simpson
left Co a nice 10-15 minute conversation
with Derwin James who you're hearing
teams are in love with yeah I mean and
that he ain't fallin past like eight I
mean I just yeah I don't think so Derwin
James is again awesome no doubt about it
definitely one of the top 20 picks of
the draft for me but I think the more
I'm hearing his team's really value him
as a top ten pick he's definitely going
the top ten or twelve for sure teams are
vol him a little bit higher than you are
they are yeah but he's still a great
frost but without a dime I know this is
the thing that just drives me crazy
about this you can't say anything about
anybody but yes he is a great prospect I
mean it's funny it's insulting to say
that someone's there Johnny
yeah right how dare you say that about
while Chris Sims coming out would have
loved yes I would a kiss somebody's ass
for that I was like something worse
you're gonna go in the penis I was I was
going I wanted to go in the consiste
erections when Sims thinks a little bit
it's typically about that
Senko we appreciate you guys so much
thanks as always for subscribing if
you're watching this on youtube click
like click subscribe if you're listening
on itunes as always thank you so much
share share share love you guys for Sims
what up peace out homies or Fenric and
for the lef koe man we say good night
happy draft week talk to you soon